being unhappy is never wholly to be
recommended but if there is any period
of life in which the mood may be
justified and in certain ways judged
important then it is roughly between the
ages of 13 and 20 it is hard to imagine
going on to have a successful or even
somewhat contented next six decades if
one is not being the beneficiary of a
good deal of agonizing introspection and
an intense dislocation in this period at
the root of adolescence sorrow and rage
is the recognition that life is hugely
harder more absurd and less fulfilling
than one could ever hitherto have
suspected or had been led to suppose by
kindly representatives of the adult
world the sentimental protection of
childhood falls away and a range of
searingly malevolent but profoundly
important realizations strike for a
start one recognizes that no one
understands that isn't quite true but of
course the more complicated any human
being is the less likely they are to be
easily and immediately understood
therefore as a child develops into an
adult the chances of those around them
exactly sympathizing with and swiftly
grasping their inner condition
necessarily decreases sharply the first
response of the teenager is to think
themselves uniquely cursed but the
better eventual insight is the true
connection with another person is
possible yet astonishingly rare this
leads one to a number of important moves
firstly to a heightened and more
appropriate gratitude towards anyone who
does understand secondly to greater
efforts to make oneself understood the
sullen grunts of early adolescence can
give way to the enormous eloquence of
the poetry Diaries and songs of later
teenagehood the most beautiful pieces of
communication humanity has ever produced
have largely been the work of people who
couldn't find anyone in the vicinity
they could talk to and lastly the sense
that one is different from other
people though it may be searingly
problematic at the time represents a
critical moment when a new generation
starts to probe at and selectively
improve upon the existing order to be 16
and find everything perfect just as it
is would be a terrifyingly sterile
position to adopt a refusal to accept
the folly error and evil of the world is
a precondition of later achievement
there really seems no alternative but to
be miserable in mid-adolescence if one
is to stand any chance of making a go of
the rest of one's life another key
realization of adolescence is that one
hates one's parents yet it is truly an
enormous tribute to the love and care of
parents if their teenage children turn
around and tell them at the top of their
voice that they loathe them it isn't a
sign that something has gone wrong
it's evidence that the child knows they
are loved the really worrying teenagers
aren't those who misbehave around their
parents and take out their random misery
on them it's those who are so worried
about not being loved they can't afford
to put a foot wrong to develop proper
trust in other human beings it can be
deeply important to be able to test a
few examples to tell them the very worst
things one can think of and then watch
them stick around and forgive one you
have to have a few goes at breaking love
to believe it can be solid and of course
once parents really are rather annoying
in many ways but that too is an
important realization we would never
leave home and become parents ourselves
if we weren't at some level compensating
for the problems mistakes and vices we
had first identified in our own parents
at the age of 14 and a half another
source of teenage soil is how many big
questions suddenly fill one's mind not
least what is the point of it all this
questioning too is vital the sort of
questions the adolescents raise tend to
get a bad name but that's more to do
with how they answer them than with the
questions themselves what is the meaning
of life why is there suffering
why does CAPA
not reward people more fairly
adolescents are natural philosophers the
true endpoint of adolescence is not as
it's sometimes suggested that one stops
asking huge questions and just gets on
with the day-to-day it's that one
acquires the resources and intelligence
to build an entire life around the sort
of big questions that first obsessed one
at seventeen lastly and most poignant
lis teenagers tend to hate themselves
they hate the way they look how they
speak the way they come across it feels
like the opposite of being loved but in
fact these isolated self-hating moments
are the start of love these feelings are
what will one day be the bedrock of the
ecstasy we'll feel in the presence of
that rare partner who can accept and
desire us back tenderness will mean
nothing to us unless we first spent many
nights alone crying ourselves to sleep
nature appears to have so arranged
things that we really can't get to
certain insights without suffering the
real distinction is between suffering
with a purpose and suffering in vain for
all the horrors of adolescents one of
its glories is that the suffering it
inflicts is largely securely rooted in
some of the most crucial developments
and realizations of adulthood
these fascinatingly miserable few years
should be celebrated for offering us
suffering at its best
thank you for watching liking and
subscribing if you want more why not
visit us in person and attend a class or
take a look at our shop at the link on
your screen now
you